nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
le Mexique reste l'un des pays les plus
dangereux au monde pour les journalistes
l'an dernier année la plus meurtrière
pour la presse dans le pays 17
journalistes ont été assassinés les
appels à l'aide de la profession ne
semblent pas entendu le gouvernement
mexicain continue de les stigmatiser
Laurence cuvilliers bonjour vous êtes la
correspondante de France 24 au Mexique
et vous allez nous emmener à tiwana près
de la frontière avec les États-Unis au
nord du pays pourquoi est-ce que c'est
cette ville que vous avez choisie pour
illustrer ce problème
tout d'abord parce que c'est une ville
qui est devenue début 2022 symbolique de
la situation dramatique que vit la
presse mexicaine ces dernières années
deux assassinats coups surcoût celui du
photographe Margarito Martinez et de la
chroniqueuse lourdes mcdonada des
meurtres qui concentrent les mots
auxquels sont confrontés les
journalistes au quotidien dans leur
travail l'insécurité provoquée par le
crime organisé et puis la corruption du
monde politique nourrit par l'impunité
et puis une deuxième raison plus
personnelle tirewana c'est là que nous
avions pour la première fois suivi des
journalistes dans leur travail lorsque
nous sommes arrivés au Mexique en 2009
ce qui nous a permis de constater à quel
point l'exercice de la profession là-bas
qui était déjà dangereux à l'époque
s'est transformé et détérioré depuis
comme vous allez le voir dans ce
reportage alors on va découvrir ce sujet
que vous avez tourné donc à tiwana avec
Matthieu commun et on vous retrouve
juste après
[Musique]
22h dans les rues de tirouana
la police vient de faire une découverte
macabre sur le pompier tonnier de
l'avenue Sanchez ta Bouada
couvrir les scènes de crimes il y en a
eu près de 2000 à tirwana en 2022 des
crimes pensées pour semer la terreur
dans la ville et son brasseur
du groupe criminel le tout suspendu aux
pompiers tonnier comme vous pouvez le
voir l'avenue a été bloquée prenez garde
au changement d'itinéraire
excellente nuit à tous les followers de
Blanco et negronodicias l'info vous a
été transmise par à Toulouse
Arturo vend ses photos en freelance et
filmant direct pour les réseaux sociaux
il s'entendait bien avec Margarito
Martinez Margarito était photographe
comme lui il a été assassiné le 17
janvier devant chez lui
on se croisait tout le temps sur les
scènes de crime s'il était encore en vie
il serait ici même à l'heure qu'il est
Margarito fut la première victime de
l'année la plus
meurtre mexicaine moins d'une semaine
après lui dans la même ville une autre
journaliste tombait sous les balles de
tueurs à gages lourdès mcdonados deux
histoires très différentes une même fin
tragique lourdès s'était fait connaître
en 2019 lors d'une conférence de presse
du président mexicain Andres manuel
Lopez au Bras d'Or
l'aide et demander justice je crains
pour ma vie
c'est un homme politique puissant qui
refuse de payer les salaires qu'il me
doit
il s'agit d'un sénateur de votre partie
et de votre prochain candidat au poste
de gouverneur pour les élections de
Basse Californie
je vais demander à notre coordinateur de
communication
qu'il s'occupe de votre cas
pour que vous obteniez justice et qu'il
n'y ait pas de trafic d'influence
pendant 6 ans lourdès avait dénoncé
devant la justice et dans les médias
l'ancien gouverneur de Basse Californie
et patrons de presse rahimoniya elle
l'accusait d'évasion fiscale et de
multiples entorses au droit du travail
Sonia denda coordinatrice d'un collectif
de journalistes de tyruana suivait de
près cette affaire
en mars 2021
pour me dire que quelqu'un avait tiré
sur sa voiture
et immédiatement elle mentionnera et mes
bonnia elle m'a dit je sais que c'est
lui parce que je le critique durement
tous les jours dans mon programme
un programme qu'elle diffusé sur les
réseaux sociaux depuis la cuisine de sa
maison
et donc en ce moment en tant que
gouverneur il vient de monter toute une
série d'arrangements avec les médias de
communication pour faire taire tous les
journalistes
le mercredi avant sa mort elle s'était
plantée devant les bureaux PSN le groupe
de presse de Rahim ebonya elle s'était
mise à crier qu'elle allait saisir la
caisse de l'entreprise
et qu'elle allait prouver que
l'entreprise ne payait pas d'impôts
la loi les oblige à me donner accès à
tous ces documents nous allons les
éplucher et porter plainte pour toutes
les entorses à la loi qui ont lieu dans
cette entreprise
quatre jours plus tard lourdès mcdonado
est tué par balle devant chez elle
nous nous sommes rendus au siège de PSN
trois personnes ont été inculpées pour
leur participation présumées au meurtre
mais raï mebonia n'a jusque maintenant
pas été inquiété par la justice
il n'y a pas grand chose à dire sur le
cas de Lourdes Maldonado elle a
travaillé dans mon entreprise
je ne la connaissais presque pas j'étais
député à l'époque où elle était recrutée
j'ai juste su qu'elle avait eu un
différent avec la direction elle a donc
porté plainte voilà tout
ce qui lui est arrivé nous a fait
beaucoup de peine mais la justice à tous
les éléments en main le président a dit
qu'il allait étudier ce cas de près il a
dû le faire pour son compte mais il ne
nous a jamais posé de questions
le procureur de l'État interrogé sur les
avancées de l'enquête affirment qu'il
attend son heure
nous sommes bloqués par l'immunité
parlementaire dont il bénéficie pour le
moment mais ça ne veut pas dire que
l'enquête ne progresse pas pendant ce
temps
et je veux être clair c'est une piste
qu'on suit de près
Margarito lui aussi se savait menacé par
le crime organisé et par une guerre de
l'information que ce livre les cartels
de la drogue depuis quelques années à
Tijuana des dizaines de profils
soi-disant informatifs sont apparus sur
les réseaux sociaux
certains véhicules des données douteuses
simples rumeurs accusations sans preuve
texte non signé impossible de savoir qui
en tirent les ficelles
Arturo les a vu se multiplient avec
inquiétude les limites entre journalisme
et propagande se sont brouillés
dangereusement
si le média n'a pas un minimum de
transparence je refuse de travailler
pour eux parce que ces pages qui
prétendent d'être des pages
d'informations en général elles n'ont
pas de site internet seulement une page
Facebook avec des textes mal écrits
ce sont les forces de l'ordre qui
prennent ces photos et les laisse
filtrer
médias a publié des photos en très gros
plan aucun journaliste ne pourrait
s'approcher aussi près d'une scène de
crime
[Musique]
et des pages comme celle-là il y en a au
moins une vingtaine à tiroirs
certains comptent semblent être en
croisade contre un cartel comme Tijuana
en guerre qui pendant des mois ne
parlaient que des méfaits de la bande du
leader criminel cabovente en diffusant
des photos extrêmement violentes des
scènes de crime elle a gagné un public
plus large que certains médias
traditionnels plus de 150 000 abonnés
le racco l'âge fait vendre
Margarito lui signait ses photos et ne
travaillait que pour des médias reconnus
mais un jour une altercation éclate
entre lui et un jeune homme qui le film
et lui lance des accusations infondées
en direct
la vidéo a été vue des milliers de fois
l'homme qui s'en est pris à Margarito
c'est un auteur d'une page Facebook
unrell vous informe il est veillé les
soupçons des journalistes de tir Juana
depuis des mois pour ces pratiques
poétiques et la manière laquée
se comportait à l'époque
n'était pas du tout journalistique et
Margarito avait commencé à en alerter
notre collectif
il était convaincu canrel Peña était un
faucon
c'est ainsi qu'on appelle ces personnes
qui sous couvert de faire du journalisme
passe des informations au groupe
criminel où se trouve la police est-ce
qu'ils ont bloqué des avenues etc
sur les lieux commencer à transmettre en
direct
il faisait des gros plans sur les
visages des policiers les plaques
d'immatriculation des véhicules de
police les numéros d'unités
quelques instants après le drame ses
amis se réunissent sur les lieux du
crime et
certains commencent à nous prévenir
anrel Peña est là il filme en direct
c'est là que j'ai foncé sur lui
dans les mois qui ont suivi
l'arrestation et l'incubation de
plusieurs auteurs présumés du meurtre
semble confirmer que le commanditaire
était bien le Cabaud vainte le chef
criminel constamment attaqué dans les
publications de Tijuana en guerre nous
avons contacté les administrateurs de la
page qui sont toujours restés anonymes
et ils n'ont pas donné suite à nos
demandes d'interview
une nuit de plus avec plus de 5 meurtres
par jour en moyenne on ne chôme pas dans
les rues de tiruana entre deux scènes de
crimes Arthur retravaille comme
chauffeur de taxi pour combler les
heures creuses
je me trouve maintenant là où viennent
d'être découverts des restes humains sur
la 8e rue
cette fois-ci certains sont arrivés
avant lui impossible de distinguer les
journalistes des simples badauds
influenceurs ou indiquent des cartels
une tête coupée vient d'être retrouvée
sur la voie publique juste devant une
école primaire
je passe le bonsoir à tous ceux qui
suivent cette transmission en direct
Alvarado on compte déjà 70 meurtres dans
la ville pendant les 10 premiers jours
de ce mois
comment 78 on approche les 80 incroyable
non
nous faisons une rencontre inattendue
entre le pénien celui qui avait accusé
margareto Martinez d'être derrière des
pages facebook au contenu douteux il
n'avait pas répondu à nos demandes
d'interview quand nous l'avions contacté
si tu as des problèmes c'est pas mes
affaires
si lui a des problèmes je m'en mêle pas
tu sais quoi en fait je parle à personne
j'ai reçu des menaces d'un cartel puis
du cartel adverse je suis dos au mur je
veux éviter les problèmes à tout prix
dans les rues de tir Juana tout est
pénombre impossible de savoir à qui on
s'adresse seul option garder ses
distances et être discret
bien sûr j'ai peur je suis un être
humain mais il faut faire le boulot il
faut que quelqu'un informe sur ce qui se
passe à Tijuana
dans un pays où l'impunité dans les cas
de meurtres de journalistes est presque
total l'arrestation d'un commanditaire
serait un signe d'espoir car pour
l'instant les mesures de protection dont
bénéficient aussi Sonia desenda n'ont
pas fait leur preuve
les crimes contre les journalistes
doivent être punis de manière exemplaire
pour décourager les agresseurs ça ne
sert à rien de assigner des gardes du
corps parce que le jour où ils veulent
te tuer et c'est déjà arrivé
il faut qu'on soit très clair sur notre
message
si vous touchez à l'un d'entre nous vous
touchez tous c'est notre seul défense
et si on doit encore verser notre sang
voici le mien et celui du prochain
[Musique]
les frontières du monde de l'information
sont loin d'être aussi clairement
délimité que le mur qui sait partir
Juana des États-Unis entre les menaces
du crime organisé et celle de la
corruption les journalistes mexicains
doivent maintenant faire face à un autre
ennemi plus difficile encore à cerner la
désinformation des sables mouvants dans
lesquels 17 d'entre eux ont perdu la vie
en 2022
et on retrouve Laurence cuvilliers à
Mexico City dans votre commentaire
Laurence vous dites que l'impunité dans
les cas de meurtre de journalistes et
presque total la justice est muselée à
ce point au Mexique
en fait c'est révélateur d'un panorama
général de la justice mexicaine c'est un
pays où en 2021 95% des crimes et délits
restaient impunis c'est un système
judiciaire aux mécanisme lourd souvent
obsolète et où les familles des victimes
sont souvent les seuls qui mènent de
vrais enquêtes de terrain alors vous
l'avez vu dans les cas de margareto et
de lourdes il y a eu des avancées mais
bien souvent les enquêtes restent
bloquées à mi-parcours les exécutants du
crime peuvent être capturés mais les
preuves pour remonter jusqu'au
commanditaires sont difficiles à
rassembler y a-t-il un soutien de la
société civile à l'égard des
journalistes leur rôle est-il considéré
comme important par la société au
Mexique
alors c'est une réflexion qu'on se fait
souvent qu'en tant que journaliste on
participe à des manifestations contre
l'impunité dans les cas d'agression
contre la presse on s'y retrouve entre
collègues soutenus par quelques membres
d'associations et d'ONG mais on ne peut
pas parler d'un véritable soutien de la
société civile il faut rappeler aussi
que c'est un pays qui compte ces
dernières années entre 30 et 35 000
homicides par an donc les assassinats
journalistes se retrouvent noyés dans un
flot de criminalité puis faut mentionner
comme vous l'avez dit en introduction
que le président mexicain adresse manuel
Lopez Obrador stigmatise constamment la
presse ce qui détériore considérablement
le soutien dont bénéficier les
journalistes dans l'opinion publique
et puis les infox Laurence les fake news
c'est une autre manière de s'attaquer à
la presse pour la décrédibiliser
oui alors au Mexique on peut parler d'un
phénomène légèrement différent celui des
canaux d'information parallèles comme
vous l'avez vu dans le reportage des
informateurs citoyens comme ils se font
appeler qui relayent des informations
non vérifiées notamment sur les affaires
de meurtre des informations souvent
accompagnées d'images chocs dont
malheureusement le Mexique regorge avec
plus de 80 meurtres par jour dans le
pays et c'est cette limite qui est en
train de se brouiller totalement entre
la pratique d'un journalisme basé sur
les informations vérifiées et ce type
d'information citoyenne qui a accaparé
les réseaux sociaux dans des villes
comme Tijuana Laurence cuvilliers
journaliste au Mexique depuis 14 ans il
correspondante de France 24 merci
Laurence c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
[Musique]